[Music]
hey it's the buns
I think the honorable thing for our
species to do is to deny our programming
stop reproducing walk hand and hand into
extinction one last midnight brothers
and sisters opting out of a raw deal
okay Wow get our ass you want some gum
gum
I have a lot of thoughts about gun
[Music]
[Laughter]
puppies puppies yeah you got one on
puppies yeah they act like they love you
but don't be fooled the second you pass
out in your kitchen they'll be the first
beasts to rip off your face and consume
it and [__] it out their ass he's got a
sick dick Dickens he'll if only there
was some sort of Medicine bill he could
take so his dick would be great just
driving a car sounds Louisiana
yes Louisiana get a load of all the
mountains cattle and the vineyards are
just me directions the only direction
we're headed is the grave you were born
dead your mother just forgot to grieve
you
but I'll send her a reminder is that
supposed to mean you're born dead your
mother just forgot to grieve you alright
that's it we're pulling off I'm gonna
kick this [__]
[Music]